This is a fascinating
article making
the rounds on the
internet recently
about how the Instagram
generation now experiences
the present as an
anticipated memory.
The success of photo
filtering apps on social media
has created a generation
of individuals
who now believe that
every present moment needs
to be experienced
as something that
will be reflected upon later.
And we take it upon
ourselves to design
what that later moment
is going to feel like.
We're living in two
realities at the same time.
It's what Daniel
Kahneman use to refer
to as the experiencing self
and the remembering self.
And they're working in concert.
They're saying, be
happy for this moment,
for this moment is your life.
But guess what,
this moment is going
to be gone like this and all
you're going to have left
is that photo filtered
vintage photograph.
All you're going
to have left is how
you choose to
remember this moment.
So you're given a pen.
You're given a chance to
decide how this moment will
be remembered, and I
think that is fascinating.
We all become artists.
We all become architects
of our mental narratives,
of our historical,
digital paper trail.
We decide who we are.
We're building maps and
those maps are subjective.
I don't think it's a bad thing.
I just think it's fascinating.
I think it liberates our desire
to be artists, our desire
to be the authors
of our own lives,
and to decide how we remember
things, to decide how we deal
with the fact that
every moment passes,
how we deal with that tragedy,
how we deal with that entropy.
At least, we're going to
italicize the memory of it.
And so yes the present is
lived as anticipated memory
because that's all we have
is the anticipated memory.
The present's gone.
It's rich, but it's gone.
And that haunts me,
but we deal with it.